why do you want to make movies to help
people feel less isolated I think for me
one of my I guess core drives as a
person is like loneliness like growing
up initially in school I didn't have a
lot of friends I was bullied a lot it
really drove me I guess creatively
filmmaking was the first thing that made
me cool I guess as a kid I was like oh
phil was a filmmaker he can make movies
and it really allowed me to make friends
because kids wanted to be involved and
you know making a movie and being actors
and you know doing cool things so I
really connected with that on a personal
level and knowing how hard it is feeling
lonely and especially as an artist too I
mean there's so much time that you are
alone
it's very introspective you know when
you're writing it's just you and your
computer and you're writing a story
that's solely in your head and and then
pretty much through the filmmaking
process even when you are collaborating
with people it still ultimately falls
back on you as it's the creator you know
and the decision maker you know are you
doing the right thing or the wrong thing
so loneliness is something I think that
drives me as a creator and a person and
movies are something that I think
bridges gaps in culture and when you're
watching a movie and you're watching
characters you're feeling something and
you're feeling connected to somebody
else
and you realize that your own personal
demons or things that everybody shares
and I think that's really important to
me as a as a filmmaker to be able to
connect with other people in that way
and to show people that you know no
matter what you're going through in life
somebody else is going through that same
exact thing like somewhere in the world
somebody has the same exact worry that
you have and that you're not alone and
that's that's really important to me did
any of the people that bullied you reach
out and say I saw your movie hey man I'm
sorry about that
you know it's it's funny you know I
think all bullying situations are
different in my situation I ended up
almost becoming friends with some of the
kids that believe me through it like
elementary school was like the bullying
period and in high school when people
start to grow up a little bit
you know we were able to develop I guess
some sort of friendship and in my
situation I realized you know that I
don't think they realized what they were
doing was as harmful as it was and I
think young kids can be very mean to
each other without realizing the damage
that they're doing so I don't hold any
of that against anybody that did it
because they were young there were 13
years old yeah you know right from wrong
but you don't have a concept of you know
how much impact you're leaving on people
so I try not to hold that against them
that's good yeah grow up and you didn't
have a good right hook to I can tell
those impactful stories
you